[Music]
[Applause]
happy thursday everyone what a great
show we got tonight as you know just
hours after our all-american christmas
tree was torched by a babbling madman
not to be confused with geraldo
a new tree was erected and it looks
absolutely fabulous
so a big thank you to that adorable tiny
elf dana perino and her tiny little elf
friends they worked all night
it's almost as fabulous looking as
harold ford jr yeah
like to welcome mr ford to his first
time on the show
you need a new agent
this show kills more jobs than china
but it's a tribute to the spirit of the
people who work here and deliver this
magnificent show you can burn down the
damn tree and we're gonna just put up
another and by we i mean not me
other people did it
i didn't put it back up the only thing i
know how to put up is a two-way bathroom
mirror
but also just hours after the fox
christmas tree was torched by a babbling
madman the babbling madman was
released cnn anchors now face more
punishment than arsonists
you win universe
also here's a funny side story a
photographer told the new york post that
the arsonist had allegedly exposed
himself to reporters outside the jazlane
maxwell trial in manhattan last week
okay that's not a funny side story
but at least we found something joe
devito and the arsonist have in common
thanks to this madman we're learning how
many crimes you can get away with
showing your junk and burning people's
stuff
what killmeade calls it tuesday
now i won't say the christmas creep's
name because that's what he really wants
and also it's very hard to pronounce is
it is it do say or is it ducey
but it's true it's ducey
the is the arsonist who torched the fox
news christmas tree was freed after his
arraignment on wednesday night because
his charges were not eligible for bail
under new liberal reform laws he has a
better chance of facing consequences
from smokey the bear
who could have seen this coming
well we all did
this whole issue has to do with the
revolving door of justice the guy that
lit the tree on fire is probably going
to get out today or tomorrow because
not a felony arson for what he did it
it's an offense under new york law where
he has to be bailed so he's going to be
out he might be out right now
it's weird to live in a world where you
can actually predict the bad news but
all you get is a shrug in return crime
is like being the guy who cleans the
restrooms at the view
you clean it up and
it's just worse the next day
but it's not like we weren't warned it's
like a weatherman who says hey you see
that category five off the coast of new
jersey and moving west at 25 miles per
hour i think you should all get the hell
out of there
and no one moves
that's our government you can say to
them look you're releasing fiends that
are about to reoffend
and like cat confronted with a simple
math problem they just stare blankly
and then of course the fiends reoffend i
could go through the examples of the
violent felons sprung from jail thanks
to bail reform but there are so many of
them that it would take up the entire
show and bleed literally into the next
hour and the last thing i want to do is
piss off evil shannon bream
but it's old news another violent
criminal is let loose to beat up another
woman sucker punch another elderly asian
burn down a christmas tree that's how it
works the justice system exists now to
keep criminals safe from consequences i
mean here's a typical scene playing out
all over
good to see you again we'll have you out
of here in a gif that'd be great i have
a uh robbery scheduled for two o'clock
today so well it is a busy time of year
for everyone we'll just run down your
pending charges uh larceny assault
shoplifting vandalism public
intoxication oh you almost forgotten
decent exposure
drug dealing drug possession weapons
possession unpaid parking tickets arson
and mail fraud
and since none of these are bail
offenses you're free to leave happy
holidays that's great officer thank you
uh did you forget your mask oh no no i
don't wear one no masks now you son of a
[ __ ] wait what what
we're trying to keep this city safe
now
so now the christmas creep is free to
roam and burn down other stuff so
where'd he go
well there is that 9 p.m open slot open
at cnn
like
i kid there's no evidence this guy
groped anyone
but we all know where he went he's now
the head writer at colbert
he turned in five cereal box tops to get
the job
last night colbert lamely joked about
the burning christmas tree that it's
getting its own show on fox but if that
were true it would instantly get better
ratings than colbert
that's that's because a christmas tree
fire is way more entertaining than a
dumpster fire
remember this
[Music]
that might be a worse crime than arson
hell even in today's legal climate a
judge would refuse him bail for that
felony but at least he's trying to be
funny and failing what's cnn's excuse
here's the cranky cricket muncher using
the arson attack to slam fox news
now no one was injured in this incident
but they could have been this is a
serious incident obviously it's
incredibly scary to feel that your
workplace is under attack
unless your workplace is the capital
then according to many many fox hosts
it's not such a big deal
oh my god only the psychos at cnn could
make an arson attack into an attack on
its target
for cnn the attack is merely an
opportunity to wag your swollen finger
at the people who are kicking your ass
every night
how imbecilic yes arson is indeed bad
but you didn't care about january 6.
what a miserable wretch if she got any
dumber she could fill chris cuomo's
seats
just his seat
so the last few days show you what's
good and what's bad about the world this
is stuff colbert or cnn don't understand
along with others who are walled off
from the consequences of unchecked crime
thanks to a progressive perversion of
incentives criminals react to them as
you would expect them to
these people are lawless but they're not
dumb
meaning if consequences no longer exist
for crime they will commit more crime
and prison was once the disincentive and
it worked which is why we got rid of it
we are now pissing on the grave of
common sense
now we were lucky that no one died the
night of that of the arson but i prefer
counting on justice and not luck
it's why i avoid casinos so the madman
walks which sends a message to others
like him repercussions no longer exists
for the most disgusting behavior whether
it's assault murder or arson
but there's good news the tree is back
up and like me it looks great
and if you keep burning it down we'll
just put up another that's the real
holiday spirit and we need more of it
now than ever
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's yes
if he were a bear attack i'd beat him
off in the woods fox news contributor
harold ford jr
if laughter is the best medicine he's
definitely not fda approved writer and
comedian joe devito
tickets to his shows are a lot like
movie endings you can't give them away
comedienne joe maggie
and she's looking forward to not
remembering the holidays fox news
contributor captain
harold welcome to the show
what a show already yes it is
so now i know you're definitely not
running for president
because this will ruin your chances has
america lost the plot if
if this continues we're done as a
country because this is kind of the
thing that holds us together it's just
law and order right
at our very core yeah and
you know one of the reasons you have
bail
when someone is arrested because you
want
you want to keep them in jail yes and if
they're going to get out there has to be
some there has to be some skin they have
in the game or others have in the game
um i thought what happened to capital
was terrible i thought what happened out
here was terrible
uh what happened on the grounds right
not far from us
and for him to be out and for us to have
to have pictures posted around in
security to ensure he didn't come up and
try to threaten or do anything to those
outside including you
something's wrong with the system bell
reform trying to ensure that non-violent
offenders and those who may end up
serving more time than if they were
convicted for the for the offense is a
smart thing but a violent offender
coddling violence encourage enabling
violent offenders um that's not democrat
that's not republican to your point
that's the core of our society we're a
rule of
a nation that is governed by a rule of
law yeah exactly we can't have
discussions or disagree with each other
if we're too scared to go outside you
know joe i thought it was kind of
interesting when i saw the pictures of
the uh arsonist he's better dressed than
you i thought that was interesting did
you notice he had like he had a number
of interesting jackets to wear yeah he
was very fashion forward he was he was
yeah meanwhile you're dressed like judd
hirsch in taxi
the first of many outdated references to
come tonight
my references are for my audience
i'm not gonna like talk about tick-tock
videos
thank you
greg that's just the relief factor
talking you don't really mean it
you know if you snort it it's just
faster acting
learn that from charlie kirk
i'm kidding i'm joking that's a joke
what was the question i don't think
there was a question the question is
what is wrong with this world joe yeah
it's it's um it's really awful to think
that you know we have people
not just this crazy guy did this thing
it's bad enough that he's he does not
seem to have suffered any penalty for it
so far yeah but that there are people
who are celebrating uh the burning down
of a religious symbol beloved by
millions of children around the world
yeah yeah you see this is something that
oh ha ha take that fox news yes it it it
really shows that this world that we
live in where things are upside down and
and this this guy um
appears to be mentally ill he's a danger
to himself and others now what about the
thrive new york city money they sent
about a billion of that turned into a
slush fund for mayor lurch's wife yes
and
you know when i think about it maybe
there's no greater sign of mental
illness than marrying bill de blasio she
should just keep that money
now
it's funny okay christmas tree is not
necessarily a religious symbol but it's
kind of become one it's a festive
religious symbol uh and you're right
there was really no outrage about it fox
was just sad because it was so beautiful
but there was no outrage i imagine if it
were a blm banner
holy
if joe
if they ever found out what you did
mackie maggie this guy
exposed himself
and we find out that must be legal too
just so everyone's clear the arsonist
exposed himself not me
i
uh
you just don't want anyone to get the
wrong idea i don't like the revolving
door of justice greg because i don't
even like
revolving doors they're
they're my second leading reason for
trips the emergency room
after falling off treadmills and ahead
of mixing bleach and ammonia
but to yes and joe's point uh i looked
up as to sit uh on statistica.com a
website that handles statisticas
that back in in 1990 when you're when
your references were only 10.
[Laughter]
uh the government spent 45 billion on
mental health and in 2020 it was
238.4 billion in mental health and to me
it seems like the only thing less
accountable than than criminals is uh is
government mental health
funding it is so true where does this
stuff go because if you walk up and down
new york city streets
you see it's it's it's a menagerie of
mental illness how about that for a
bit of alliteration cat a menagerie if
you will of mental illness
menagerie great job thank you very much
thank you so much um i love how cnn used
the arson to let go but but remember
what you guys did that's amazing anyway
yeah
it is it is i don't know if it's amazing
you can kind of expect it because also i
don't know anybody
here or elsewhere that didn't say that
january 6th was bad i know exactly i've
said it so many times and i feel like i
have to say it again now it was bad guys
i think it was horrible yeah because
everybody wants to i don't know where
this narrative came from that we don't
think it's bad yeah um and yeah the
christmas tree thing i think is still
remarkable but again
huge day for arsonists yeah it wasn't
like just like a symbol of whatever love
and whatever's
i'm not really a christmas gal like i
don't want to set it on fire but you
know whatever it is
it was also a very expensive one it was
like half a million dollars he
completely torches it and he gets to go
home yes
that's a i mean if i were an arsonist
which i'm definitely not right i would
be very excited well the thing is i
believe like setting fire to the tree
is no different than setting fire to a
trash can like if you start a fire in a
trash can because there's no human
potential of being in it so unless you
know you're like uh
there's always there's human potential
being anywhere yes but that's why that's
right so even the cost is is not
relevant it's amazing isn't it yeah and
you know and people forget that because
firefighters do such a great job that
even for something like that that they
got under control very quickly someone
could have easily died it was a blaze
it's very dangerous yeah it was but you
know what i got to tell you we got a
great hour of programming out of it with
the 5.
so burn those trees no i'm kidding
that's a joke
but it really was nice we had a big
crowd out there it was quite enjoyable
we also had it was catered so i had like
pigs in the blanket
i love pigs in the blanket
yeah hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else